foreign
welcome to another video by simply learn
in this video python data visualization
tutorial we will teach you everything
that you need to know about data
visualization in Python
data visualization is the field of
representing data that you already have
in a visual form which makes it easier
for both you and the user to understand
it
python has mainly three main libraries
which help in data visualization
in this tutorial we will teach you
everything that you need to know about
these three different libraries and how
you can use them to visualize your data
better
to begin we will start with the
matplotlib library we will explain
matplotlib to you teach you about the
different types of plots and how to plot
different graphs and sub graphs in
matplotlib we will also look at how you
can include graph parameters like titles
Legends and labels into your matplotlib
graphs
then we will move on to c bond
we will explain what is c bond to you
and then understand python c bond better
with the help of a Hands-On demo feel
free to follow along with it
and finally we will take a look at the
bokeh library offered by python which is
used to make interactive graphs in
Python
we will explain different graphs like
scatter charts line charts pie charts
histograms bar plots
Etc in bokeh and how you can Implement
them and make them user friendly and
Interactive
and finally we will take a look at the
layout function in Python which is used
to make
interactive web interfaces
so let's get started we're going to
study
so what's in it for you what is matplot
Library types of plots plotting graphs
and sub graphs adding a graph inside a
graph graph parameters title label
Legend line graphs line types color and
transparency canvas grid and axes range
2D plots scatter step bar fill between
radar chart histogram Contour image 3D
surface image and then we'll hit a
practice example pie chart
so let's start with what is matplot
library matplot library is an open
source drawing Library which supports
Rich drawing types it is used to draw 2D
and 3D graphics and there are so many
packages in the matplot library we're
going to cover the basics and there are
so many packages that sit on top of the
matplight library that we can't even
cover them all today but we'll hit the
main one so you have a good
understanding of what the matplot
library is and what the basics can do
you can understand your data easily by
visualizing it with the help of matplot
Library you can generate plots
histograms bar charts and many other
charts with just a few lines of code and
here we have some basic types of plots
you can see here that we'll go into we
have the bar chart the histogram boy I
use a lot of histograms in my stuff
scatter plot line chart pie chart and
area graph let's start plotting them and
to do this I'm going to be using Jupiter
notebook you can use any of your python
interfaces for programming or scripting
and running it of course we here really
like the Jupiter notebook for doing
basic a lot of basic stuff because it's
so visual and in our Jupiter notebook
which opens up in this case I'm using
Google Chrome you can go up here to New
and we'll create a new Python 3 and set
that up
if you're not familiar with Jupiter
notebook we do have a tutorial that
covers some of the basics of that and
you'll look at any of our tutorials they
usually cover a number of them showing
how to set up Jupiter and Anaconda I
myself use Jupiter through anaconda in
fact let's go ahead and open that up and
just take a look at this see what that
looks like you can see your anaconda
Navigator if you install it it will
automatically install the jupyter
notebook but it also installs a lot of
other things I know some people like the
QT console for doing python or spider
I've never used them I actually use
notepad plus plus as one of my editors
and then I use the Jupiter notebook a
lot because it's so easy to have a
visual while I'm programming and even
simple script in Python I'll take it
from the Jupiter notebook and then do a
save as you always go under file and you
can download as a Python program so
that'll download it as an actual python
versus the IPython that this saves it as
so let's go ahead and dive in and see we
got going here and let's go ahead and
put matplot Library tutorial and I'm
going to turn this cell into a markdown
so it doesn't actually run it we can see
it has a nice little title there that's
all Jupiter notebook
and then from matplot library let's
import
Pi lab
back one and then let's go ahead and
just print
we'll go pylab and the version let's go
ahead and run this so we're going to
import our pylab module from the matplot
library and we find out the word version
1.15.1 always important to note the
version you're in probably I was reading
an article that said the number one
thing that python programmers struggle
with is remembering what version they're
working in and making sure that they're
going from one platform to the other
with the same version and if we're going
to graph things I think we need some
data to graph so we're going to import
numpy as NP now if you're not familiar
with numpy definitely go back and check
out our numpy tutorial there's so many
different things you can do with it
dealing with reshaping the data and
creating the data we're just going to
use it to create some data for us and
there is a lot of ways to create data
but we're going to use the np.line space
so we're going to create a numpy array
and the way you read this is we're going
to create numbers between 0 and 10 and
we're going to create 25 of these
numbers so we're just going to divide
that equally up between 0 and 10. and if
we have x coordinates we should probably
have some Y coordinates and we'll do
something simple like x times X plus two
and let's just take a look we're going
to print X and print
y let me go ahead and run this and let's
see we got going on here so we have our
x coordinates which is 0 0.4.83
Etc and you can look at this as an X Y
plot so where we have 0 we have two and
we have 0.416 we have 2.17 and just as a
quick reminder we're going to do print
in prax comma y dot reshape 25 comma two
and the reason I want to do this is I
want to show you something here a lot of
times a program returns X comma Y and
it's an array of X comma y x comma y x
comma Y and so when you're working with
the pi plot
you have to separate it out and reshape
it so if I start off with pairs like
this I can reshape them if I know
there's 25 pairs in there I can switch
the 2 and the 25 and this is kind of
goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape so
I'm going to reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25.
and if I run that you'll see I end up
with the same output as the X Y the two
different arrays in here
and this is important that we want X and
Y separate again that's all numpy stuff
but it's important to understand that
this is a format that matplot Library
works with it works with an array of x's
and they should match your array of y's
so each one has 25 different entities in
it and then for our basic plotting of
this data it only takes one command to
draw graph of this data and so we use
our from up here we imported pylab we
take our PI lab and the keynet lender
there is plot for plotting a line and
then we want our x coordinates and our Y
coordinates and we'll throw in R and the
r simply means red so we're going to
draw the line in red let me go and run
that
you can actually switch this around if
you wanted to do different there's B for
blue we have a lot of fun yellow hard to
see yellow there we go but we'll go
ahead and stick with red run and when
you're doing presentations with these
try to be consistent you know if the
business and the shareholders send you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
you use red for losses in your graph
try to be consistent use green for
profit for money you don't have to
necessarily use green but it's whatever
they're using whatever the company is
using try to mirror that that way people
aren't going to be confused if you
switch your data around and every time
one graph has red for loss and one graph
has blue for loss it gets really
confusing so make sure you're consistent
in your graphs and your coloring and
something to know because we're going to
cover this in a minute this is your
canvas size so we have a canvas here and
what we're going to do next is we're
going to look at sub graphs okay so
let's take our PI lab and create a sub
plot
okay one of the things also to know when
we're working with the matplot library
I'm not sending when I do this this is
my drawing canvas the pi lab so once
I've imported the pylab I'm drawing my
images on there very important to know
and with the subplot we're going to give
it some different values and we're going
to represent by rows columns and indexes
and let's do one two one so it's going
to be the first row second column and
the index is I think you can stack your
graphs and things like that we don't
worry too much about indexes but rows
and columns we want to go ahead and use
Row one and column two and if we're
going to have one object we should
probably have two but before we do that
we have to plot data onto the subplot so
the order is very important and we're
going to stick with our X comma Y and
let's do this we're going to add in a
third parameter here remember we did Red
we're going to add shorthand dash dash
for dashed lines so the this plots the
data into Row 1 column two and if we're
going to do that let's do another one
pilab dot subplot and if we're going to
do Row one let's do column two and index
two
and this time we're going to add G for
green and this denotes a style and if
we're going to set up our pylab subplot
here we go all right lab we gotta go
ahead and plot that pi
lab plot
and instead of X Y we want y comma X
Oops I messed up this is in the wrong
spot there we go we'll move that down
here real quick because that goes in the
plot part so the subplot tells that the
row column and index and the pi plot
tells it what data in this case we
switch them and the color and then the
style shorthand and let's go ahead and
run that
and you'll see it takes this canvas
splits it in two and now we have two
different graphs and we have the red one
with dashed lines and we have the green
one which is has little stars going up
and if we take this and let's just um
just for fun let's change this and run
that with an index of one it puts them
both on the same index it also gives me
a warning because it's a strange way of
doing two subplots there's this
depreciated there's another way to do it
but most people just ignore that warning
because it's not going to go away
anytime soon now that's using the same
setup what happens if we do instead of
this let's change the column on here and
find out what happens
and if we do the column
I didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep our
column as 2 and let's change the row on
the second one to two and run that
and you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together it can cause us some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where I made some changes I said row two
and look what happens when I change to
column two so I now have Row 2 column
two index two I squished it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does and there's all kinds
of different things you really have to
just play with these numbers so you get
a handle on them because
you know we get repeated 164 times
according to Cambridge University if
it's completely new to you and you can
see right here where we go three run
there we go but you can see it takes a
little bit sometimes to play with these
and get the numbers right hopefully hit
the wrong one that's why let's go three
there three there run
there we go now it's overlapping so I
have this doubled over here on the right
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
this with the where we have column and
row two and the two different indexes so
they appear nice and neatly side by side
and then as we just saw as we were
flashing through them we can put them on
top of each other
and let me just highlight that and copy
it down here
paste it down there and here we have one
two one and then we'll do one two one
also for this one and that puts the two
subplots directly on top of each other
it gives us that warning and you can see
we now have two different sets of data
graphed on top of each other and you can
also see how it did the indexes since
one of them is from 0 to 10 that's the
green one on the x-axis and the other
one is from 0 to 10 on the y axis so it
took the greatest value of either one
and then used those as a shared value
so let's next look at operator
description and we'll go ahead and turn
this cell into a markdown and run that
so it looks nice so fig and remember I
talked about the canvas earlier I
briefly mentioned it we're going to look
a little bit more at the canvas later on
but that's what the figure is FID we're
going to add axes so we're going to
initialize a subplot add the subplot in
rows and columns and all kinds of
different things with this that you can
do let's look at that code and see
exactly what's going on and I want you
to notice that there's fig which is the
actual canvas in the matplot library and
ax is commonly used to refer to the
subplots so we're creating subplots
you'll see ax equals PLT subplot
earlier we did the pi lab so let's go
ahead and import Pi plot from matplot
library and we're going to do it as PLT
you'll see that a lot that's really the
standard in the industry is to call it
PLT just like pandas's PD and numpy
array is NP certainly you can import it
as whatever you want but I would stick
to the standards and we're going to do
the same graph as we did above with the
pi lab but with the PLT so if it looks
familiar there's reason we're doing this
because we want to show you how the
figure part works and working with the
canvas goes but we're going to do the
same plot as we did before and we'll
call it fig and we're going to set that
equal to plot figure so there's our
figure or our canvas on there and let's
create a variable called axes and we're
going to set that equal to Fig dot add
axes
and in this we're going to control the
Left Right the width the height of the
canvas from zero to one and so we can go
ahead and I'm just going to put some
stuff in there I got 0.5
0.1.8.8 so when you're looking at this
this is a zero to one or you could say
50 percent 10 80 80 percent but it's a
control it's going to control your left
and your right along with the width and
the height so the width and the height
we're going to use 80 percent and we're
going to have like a little indent on
the left and the right and this would
look familiar from above xcs.plot X
comma Y and then let's give it a color
how about red since we're recreating the
same graph let's keep it uniform oops
and it helps if I use a ax i s instead
of axes I don't know where that came
from but this looks identical to the one
we had up above so here's our axis plot
X comma y of red same graph same setup
but this time we've added a variable
equal to the figure dot add axes so our
plot figures our canvas our axes is what
we're working in and then axis.plot X
comma Y and again we can draw Sub graphs
we put that down here
[Music]
just like we did before and a little
different notation here we're going to
have fig comma axes equal PLT Dot
subplots
and in here it's going to be the number
of rows we're going to do one row
in columns equals two so if you remember
before that's what we did we had one row
with two different graphs on it we're
going to do the same thing but know how
we did this here's our figure our canvas
and our axes we're going to create
actually two different axes we're going
to create Row one column two and so axes
is an array of information so we can
simply do
four let's do X in axes
and this will now look familiar X Dot
Plot we're going to do X comma y we'll
go ahead and make it red keep everything
looking the same remember nice uniform
graphs everything looks the same and if
we go ahead and run this
you'll see we get two nice side by side
graphs so just as we had before the same
look the same setup
and just for fun let's change in columns
to three we'll run that and now you'll
see we'll have three on there and let's
see if we make it a little bit more
interesting we'll do in rows equals to
two and you can see down here we're
going to get in the tribute there
because it's trying to scrunch
everything together so it does have a
limit how much stuff you can put in one
small space that's important to know you
can fix that by changing the canvas size
which we'll look at in just a minute and
there's other ways to change it on here
but here we go we can do in rows two and
columns equals one you can see two nice
images right above each other we'll go
back to the original one row two columns
side by side left to right and we can
also draw a picture or graph inside
another graph
and that's kind of a fun thing to do
it's important to note that we can layer
our stuff on top of each other which
makes for a really nice presentation so
let's have a fig create another figure
so we're going to start over again with
our canvas we set that equal to
plt.figure
so there's our new canvas and let's do
axes we'll call it axes one and two axis
one equals fig dot add axes remember
this from earlier and this here similar
numbers we used before saying how big
this axis is this figure in the axis is
so this is going to be the big
axes and let's do axes two equals
another figure at axes and then
0.2.5.4.3 and if we're going to do this
they need data on them so let's go ahead
and plot some data on our axis so axis1
Dot Plot and we'll make this simply X
comma y comma make it red and then let's
go axis true Dot Plot and let's reverse
them y comma X comma green there we go
doing what I told you not to do you
shouldn't be swapping axes around and
plotting your data in five different
directions because it's confusing let's
go ahead and run this and see what this
looks like and then let's talk a little
bit about this we talked about the
0.2.5.4.3 and let me just grab The
annotation for that that's left right
width and height so we have in here that
this is going to be left right so here's
our left is point one n 0.5 and we look
you know what let's just play with this
a little bit what happens when I change
this to 0.1 it moves it way over to the
left so there's our 0.1 so we can make
this point four run that there we go so
you can see how you can move it around
the branches on here 0.2 0.5 is the left
so that's the right so see what happens
when we do point oh let's make this
point one and that actually is they had
it down a left right I thought this was
wrong that's actually how far from the
bottom let me switch that on here bottom
there we go so we had here on this we
can go ahead and put that back to 0.5
and run that and this is 0.3 let's make
this point three also and that is the
width and then
if there's the height we can make that
really tiny actually let's do 0.2 and
let's run that and you can see it
changes the height on there let me make
it even smaller 0.2 by 2.2 and as you
can see you can get stuck playing with
this to make it look just right it can
sometimes take a little bit this
certainly once you have the settings if
you're doing a presentation you try to
keep it uniform unless it doesn't make
sense for the graph you're working on
try to keep the same color as the same
position and the same look and feel
and I mentioned earlier we can adjust
the canvas sides this is from earlier I
just copied it down below we're going to
re-plot the same data we've been looking
at and what we can do is we can change
the figure size to 16 by nine and let me
run that and show you what that looks
like so it fills the whole screen and
then if you are normally when you're
working on the screen you don't worry
too much about this we can set the DPI
to 300 run that
there it goes this is your dots per inch
and if you are doing an output of this
and you're printing a hard copy you want
the higher quality I would suggest
nothing under 300 if it's a professional
print you might get a little less than
that but whenever I'm doing professional
graphics and printing them out on
something 300 dots per inch is kind of
the minimal on there
you can go a lot higher too but keep in
mind the higher you get the more memory
it takes the more lag time and the more
resources you use so usually 300 is a
good solid number to use in your dots
per inch and you can see a drill These
are nice it draws a nice large canvas
here which is 16 by nine and then the
DPI is 300 on here's a little higher
quality and just out of curiosity I
wonder how long it takes to draw
something double that size 600 and you
can see here where at 600 DPI it's going
to take a while there it goes just
because it's utilizing a lot more
graphics on there and let me just go
back to the 300 now we'll actually do
let's do a 100. you're not going to see
a difference on this because it is web
based Graphics are pretty low and up
here you saw I did this with the plot
figure this works the same if I do
figure axis subplot figure size and then
we'll go ahead and do axes
plot
X comma y comma we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this and you
should get almost the same thing here
here's our axes on the subplot on here
with the fixed size and the DPI let me
take this all out let me just
move all that real quick run it again
there we go now we're back to our
original figure and let's look at other
some of the other things you can do with
this
one of the things we do is we can set a
title for the axis so axis set title
you'll see right here since I put this
on the axis it's the main title for the
whole graph
and if you're going to have a title you
should also label so we can label our X
label and we can set our y label in this
case we're just going to call it X and Y
keep it nice and uniform and if we run
this you'll see that we've added a nice
X label and Y label whoops where did
they go and it turns out in this
environment that you have to put it
before the title so let me go ahead and
put it before the title and there's our
x y and we run that and of course we can
also do upper size a little bit so you
can see what's going on a little better
so here we have X label X if you come
down here you'll see our X label and our
y label we can of course change this to
X
label you can change this to y
and be whatever you want on here of
course and our title graph there we go
run so here we have our title of graph
our y label and our X label all set up
on our nice little plot and then before
we move on to the next section let's do
more thing on here we have a thing
called The Legend and we're going to do
we're going to set our ax Legend label
one label two up here it's a format for
it but let's go down here and actually
use it I'm going to do two different
plots we're going to have axes plot X by
x times x squared and X cubed and if I
run this you'll see it puts two nice
graphs on the setup on there but it's
nice to have a legend telling you what's
going on so for the legend we can
actually do axes since we have the two
plots Legend and on here we've created
an array and we have y equals x squared
Y equals X cubed you can actually put
this as whatever you want those are just
strings and then location two and let's
go ahead and run this and see what that
looks like and you can see it puts a
nice Legend on the upper left hand
corner location two we can do location
three and run it and it drops it down to
the bottom
one I can't remember where that's at
there we go upper right so each one of
these is a number that refers to the
different locations on the screen zero
kind of have to play with them or look
them up to remember where they're at but
they do work it just kind of moves
around depending on where you want your
Legend data on there so on this section
we cover the title the graph the Y
labels and legends this is we're getting
into some starting to look really fancy
here so we now have something we can
actually put out you'll see the title of
the graph looks a little fuzzy so I
might in a web setup put the DPI up a
couple notches maybe put it at 200 100
might work fine just so you know
something to notice on here when you're
playing with these different things we
had our subplots DPI equals oh let's do
200 and see what that looks like so you
can see it now is a lot clearer it's
also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
DPI dots per inch so the next section is
let's look at some graph features we're
going to look at line color transparency
size and a few more things on here and
oops I forgot the main title so we have
our figure and our axes equals our plot
and subplots and I'll go ahead and do a
DPI equals 150 so the graph comes out
nice and large and easy for you to see
let's go ahead and do three plots on
here we'll do X by X plus one so it's
going to be a straight line plot
X Plus X plus two
and axes Dot Plot
x x
plus three this looks like we're doing
nearest neighbor setup or showing how it
uh located data and putting your lines
on there between the nearest neighbors
there we go so it draws a nice little
graph with three lines on it one of the
things we can do is we can control the
alpha on this oops and you can actually
see the when they did these lines it
automatically pulls in different colors
for your setup so there's some automatic
automatic things going on in there and a
lot of times we do that comma R but
we're going to do color equals red
another notation on here let's go ahead
and run this now we have a bright red
line down there and with the matplot
library you're not limited to Red you
can also use the one of many different
color references as you see here with
the pound sign one one five five DD
which just is just blue and we could do
the same thing with another color on
here which it turns out to be green that
can just as easily do this green
blue oops there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what I want to do is I want to
make this we're going to say What's
called the alpha on this and we're going
to set this equal to 0.5
so this is halfway see-through when I
run this and it's almost going to look
pink because you can see through it and
let's change this just a little bit just
to make this kind of fun let's Square it
there we go run it so now we have this
nice square that comes up and you can
see when it crosses it because I plotted
these two lines after it and they have
no Alpha the red is behind those lines
or in this case pink because we did the
alpha halfway through so let's go ahead
and do this Alpha equals 0.5
and oh you know what instead of squaring
it let's take it to the 0.5 power
that'll be kind of interesting to see
what that does we'll just go to keep it
squared there we go and run that and
let's go back and look at this where it
crosses over and the first thing you see
right here is on the blue is kind of
light blue now you can see how the two
colors add together you get almost a
purple on there so I can clearly see
where the red crosses the blue line and
then the green just blanks it over
because I didn't do any opaqueness no
Alpha
so this is great if you have lots of
data that crosses over and you need to
be able to track those lines better and
we're going to do this 0.5 and we'll run
that oops I Did equals 0.5 let me go
ahead and run that and so you can see
right here now you can easily see the
red line how it crosses the green and
the blue down here and if we want to we
can do this as the default is one is
solid so we can change this all to 0.8
let me just do that oops 58 eight there
we go run up so must you hit a wrong
button there let me try that again I
accidentally get rid of a bracket and
let's go ahead and run that and we come
down here and look at this you can still
see where it passes behind them but the
green dominates and the blue dominates
because we're now at 80 percent instead
of 50 percent when you can do less
that's kind of fun although at some
point the lanes kind of fade
so 0.5 is usually the best setting on
there we have a nice pastel here at 0.3
and you can easily see where they cross
over and just like you can play with the
colors we can play with line width and
you know Let's do let's try DPI 100 and
see what that looks like on my screen
equals 100 and we'll go ahead and just
take our ax plot
let's do four of these lines just so you
can see how they look next to each other
real quick here there we go
and if I run this they should all appear
the same it automatically does different
colors on there so let's do color equals
blue
I forgot my quotation marks there we go
and we'll go ahead and just make these
all blue just for purposes of being nice
and uniform and then what I want to do
is I want to do the line width
width equals
0.25 and let's just copy and paste that
down here
let's do equals one
about 1.5 and let's do one just make
this equal to two let's see what that
looks like and we do that you can see it
goes from a very thin line at 0.5 a 1
our 1.5 and 2 which is twice the width
of the one and if we're going to do
different sizes we had different colors
we had our Alpha scheme let's take this
whole thing here let's paste it down
here and do another one but instead of
line width let's look at Styles and
something to note here you can actually
abbreviate this with LW so line width
can also be Point let's just do
everything point two and let's set up a
line style we'll do the first one dashes
so let me just paste that down here so
I'm not doing a lot of extra typing
there we go
this out so we have our dashed we can do
a dash dot we'll just do the dash die
here and a colon here there we go and
there's a lot of different options we'll
look at a few more as we go down for
different ways of highlighting data but
when you look at this we have everything
as a line width of two and now we have a
straight line we have a dashed line or a
dot dash and a dot dot dot line
and then another thing we can add on
here is we're going to do here's our ax
plot and we did X let's do X plus four
so it goes right on the top and do color
black line with 1.5 so it's a smaller
line and we're going to take the line
and we're going to set dashes so look
I've changed some of the notation here
for my line and my X plot so I can set
my line comma equal to X plot and then I
can change the line settings this way
and when I run this let me run that on
here you'll see the 5 10 15 10 creates a
series of dashes that are varied in
length Link in this case they alternate
between a short Dash and a long Dash and
we can play with these numbers curiosity
always has me what happens when you play
with the numbers just to see what they
look like let's do this and let's paste
this down here I'll do two of these just
because they're kind of fun to play with
and let's change this from 10 to 3 and
we're going to change this one from 15
to to four and let's run that
you can see the differences in the lines
oops very a little bit confusing on
there because I forgot to change the
lines are all on top of each other so
let me change that really quick here and
let's run that and now you can see
here's our original dashed line
alternating when I change these numbers
on the second one the very end value to
3 you can see now we have dashes of five
let's see I'm going to guess this is a
dash is a five skip ten dashes of 15
skip 3 and then it goes back to the
beginning dashes five dashes skip 10 15
dashes skip three and of course the last
one we just switched up a little bit it
looks a lot more uniform because I'm
using two sets of ten or if I did
something like this and changed it to 30
it really becomes pronounced as far as
the distances between them and instead
of four let's go let's put 30 here also
30 by 30 there we go really pronounced
on that one and let's look at one more
important group for plotting our data
and in this we're gonna here's our plot
we started with with the X Plus One X
plus two X plus three and did it in Blue
on this one's three or four different
blue lines
and this property we want to add the
actual plots so you can see where the
plots are on the graph and for that we
might have marker equals o and if we run
this you'll see it puts a DOT for each
of these and there's 25 dots because we
have 25 x values so we actually have
zero in each of the different values of
X Y are then plotted here with the dots
and we don't want to just limit
ourselves to dots
can also do plus sign that's another
option dots is most common I'll actually
like the dots the best if we do the plus
signings here puts a nice crosshairs or
plus sign on there and we can do a
marker there's a number of different
markers you can use
and I think this one was it s is another
one which is a nice square and that's
actually a good one s for square o for
period okay that's just kind of weird so
you can see that probably on these
markers another one is uh number one so
if we run that you'll see we now have
these little hatch marks and let's take
oh let's just go with the o on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some of the stuff we're going to
do here on just a second let's do Marker
size equals two
change that to five and run that and you
can see here it's a nice little tiny dot
versus uh the size dot here this is
interesting because it said two I
thought it would be bigger
but if you do 0.5 it's even smaller and
let's just do 10 to see what that looks
like run that looks huge so marker size
a lot of these are dependent on the DPI
and the setups there's things that
switch around as far as the way the size
shows up you got to be a little careful
when you change one setting it can
change all the other markers and then
let's take our Square on here
and we'll do we have marker size we also
have marker face we'll set that equal to
Red of course we let me take change the
so it's up one notch we'll run that
whoops must have missed typed something
on here and I did it's marker face color
equals red and so when I run that you
can now see I have the squares on there
with the marker face color of course we
can mix and match these come down here
we'll make this instead of let's let's
make this plus seven and we'll make this
size 15
marker face color equals and we'll do
what green just because there we go run
very hard to actually see what's going
on there still 25 dots that kind of
overlap as you can see they print them
over each other and of course if we
really wanted to make it look horrible
we could just make that really huge
generally though you'd want something a
little bit smaller and cuter we'll just
try doing it this way there we go that's
too small to even see the face so four
you start to see the face on there
around four maybe on eight eight might
be a good number for this there we go
eight again that all just depends on
what you're trying to show on display so
we've covered a lot of stuff here as far
as our lines we've covered opaque with
our Alpha setting on there give us some
nice pastels you can see how they
overlap and how they cross over we
covered the line width different size on
there different formats for the line
itself and these are all you can combine
all these so you can have our line width
equals two line style equals she can
bring this down here also to the markers
and then we added markers in just enter
the circle a plus sign the square a
little tick which uses a one then we add
a marker size and a marker color face
and we combine those you see we get a
nice different series of representations
we also briefly mentioned color where
you didn't have to use like in here we
used color black from someplace up here
and have to find it we use the actual
number for the color as opposed to I
changed them to red and blue so you get
very precise on the color if you have
very specific color set that you need to
match your website or whatever you're
working on all of those are tools in the
matplot library so we have one more
piece to formatting the graph so we want
to show you and then we have two big
sections we're going to go over the
different graphs that they have along
with a challenge problem so let's go in
the last section we're going to look at
is limits we're going to limit our data
so this first parameter is going to
paste in there we're going to create our
subplots one two so one row two columns
we're going to do a figure size a 10
comma five this would all look familiar
now since we've done a number of them
and we're going to go ahead and plot and
this is an interesting notation you
should notice here our axis zero so one
we've used instead of you can just
iterate through them but they're just an
array so it's an array of zero is still
the axes of the first axis out of two
and we're going to plot x x squared x x
cubed line width two so we're going to
go ahead and just plot two graphs right
on top of each other without doing
multiple plots on here and we'll set the
grid equal to True one here let's go
ahead and run that and you can see here
are two plots with the x value going
across and I'm going to do something
similar and by the ways you can just if
you look at it you can see the Grid on
there that's all that is easier to spot
the data going across we're going to
take the same data for axes one so we
have our plot of x x squared x and x
cubed line with two and this time we're
going to take our axes 1 and do y limit
that's actually set underscore y limit
this is the y axis so it's going to be
an array of two two values and we'll do
zero comma 60 I'm just making these
numbers up the guys in the back actually
made them up I'm just using their
numbers and we're going to set the x
limit
and let's set the x limit as if we get
our brackets there 2 comma 5. so it's
the same data going in and but we're
setting a limit on it let's go ahead and
run that and let's see what it comes out
of and here we have the Y limit 0 to 60.
so we're looking at just the lower part
of this curve here up to here and we
have the X limit two to five so that
starts right here at 2 and you can see
very different graphs this is kind of
nice because you could actually put one
of these on top of the other if you
wanted to draw Focus to one part of a
graph remember how we did that earlier
one inside the other but just a quick
note you can easily limit your graph and
re kind of reshape the way it looks
quite easily and we can also add that
grid down there if we want a grid
we'll run that and add the Grid in there
oops I guess you have to do the grid
beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
may double check your order when you're
printing these things out it also helps
if I change it to one so in this case it
might not be the order I wonder if we'll
go back here as one there we go so it
doesn't matter the order and grid but
you can set the grid for easy viewing in
here nice setup on there but you can see
how we can limit the data so let's start
looking at some other 2D graphs and make
this cell a markdown so we run it as a
nice pretty title to it and let's go
ahead and create some data with an NP
array we'll do 0 to 5 on here there we
go and let's look at four common graphs
we'll put them side by side so we'll do
a figure our axis equals plot subplots
one four columns and then figure size
hopefully will fit nicely on here it
seems to do a pretty good on here and
I'll go and just run that since we're in
there run you'll see I have my four
blank plots on here
and we'll start with axes of zero the
set title
and we want this to be a scatter plot
scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axes of zero
getter easy to remember scatter a bunch
of plots on there we'll do our n we can
do X or n there and let's go ahead and
do axis set title scatter up already did
that we're just going to do scatter
that's how you do it on there notice how
you create a scatter plot with simply
with the scattered control and we'll do
let's do the variable X X Plus let's
throw some Randomness in here use these
Scatter Plots are have a lot of random
numbers connected to them that's why
they do them on there and so the bigger
the X gets the bigger the randomness so
0.25 times the randomness and what we
should end up down here is with the
scatter plot and you can see as you go
up it just kind of has some random
numbers and moves up and down the line
but plus just the points so if you
remember from back up here where we did
marker this is plotting basically just
the marker so it's a scatter plot
probably less used is a step plot so for
X is one we'll go ahead and do a step
plot so you can see what that looks like
and this time I'll use our n value
instead of X we generated that n value
up here and so for this we have n n
times two or N squared n times 2 N
squared line width equals two and if we
run that it creates a nice Step Up
let's see so we've got a scatter plot
we've got a step plot let's do a bar
plot
and we'll use the same formula in N
squared alignment centered because you
can have them left or right with 0.5 and
Alpha if you remember correctly that's
how opaque it is let's see what that
looks like on there so we have some nice
you can see here a nice bar plot it
should look very similar to the step
plot but color it in
and we can change the width let's see
what happens we do 0.9 run and if we
take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
alpha we can take the alpha out too and
run that so now you have the solid
colors and if we take out the center
and run that everything you really can't
see the shift on here because that's
actually the default on this but these
are common settings for the bar graph
let me just put them back in there there
we go alignment center and Alpha now I
can't say I have Houston step craft very
much there's certain other certain I
guess domains of expertise that require
a step graph but the scatter plot and
the bar graph very common especially the
bar graph and we'll look at histograms
here in just a minute so I use
histograms a lot especially in data
science but this is nice if you have
very concrete objects somebody how many
people wearing yellow hats that kind of
thing but if we're going to do that
let's go ahead and do the last one which
I see a lot more in the Sciences
certainly using the data science but
more like for mapping I saw publication
on solar flares and they're discussing
the energy and so filling in the graph
gives it a very different look so we're
going to do the fill between and it's
just like you think it'd be it's fill
between but with a underscore between
and we'll do x and x squared and x and x
cubed and we'll do color green and Alpha
again in case you had other data you
want to plot on there you can see it
forms a nice squared coming up here and
also if you look at the bottom one is
your squared value the upper line is
your cubed value and then it fills in
everything in between if you remember
from calculus this would be if you had
like a car a motor and efficiency they
would talk about the efficiency going up
and the loss and you're looking for the
space or the area between the two lines
so it gives you a nice visual of that
now let's look at a few more basic
two-dimensionals so we have our figure
figure size on here we're going to do a
radar chart to be honest I've never used
a radar chart in business or in data
science I can't find a reason to use one
now so the first line for doing a radar
chart we have to add axes into the
figure and with this this actually
creates our all this let's run it so you
can see what it creates it creates it's
a nice looks like you're on a submarine
and you're tracking The Hunt for Red
October or something like that and it
needs all of these the polar is the fact
that we're doing polar coordinates zero
zero point six point six has to do with
the size if you take out any of these
things and run them you get just a box
if you take out the other half you
pretty much get nothing in there and if
you change these numbers and change them
a little bit you can see it gets bigger
they hit 0.6 on here I'll go ahead and
leave it as one because that's just kind
of fun it's all about the size on here
the height and the width and then let's
create some data T equals NP line space
and this is 0 to 2 times NP times pi so
if you remember that is the distance
across and we're going to generate a
hundred points so this is just the thing
of data we're putting together let me
simply do an ax Dot Plot and in this
case let's do T comma T which would be a
diagonal line and a regular chart and
we'll give it a nice color equals blue
and line width equals three let's see
what that looks like and we can see here
a spiral coming out remember this would
be just a diagonal line on a regular
chart what happens if we take this and
instead of T times 0.5 there we go and
you can see it slightly Alters the way
it spirals out we could do T times two
spirals out a little quicker so it's
kind of just a fun like I said I've
never used a radar chart it's a column
but you can always think of radar in a
submarine kind of looks like one of
those or on an airplane and none of this
would be complete if we didn't discuss
histograms oh my gosh do I use a
histogram so much and we'll use our
numpy that we have set as NP to generate
oh it looks like we have a hundred
thousand variables we're going to set
equal to n and of course we create our
figure and our axes from subplots one
two figure size 12 14. so we're going to
look at two different variations of the
histogram and we'll set a title default
histogram set our title there and then
this is simply his
for histogram and we'll just go ahead
and put in our n in there and let me run
this and see what that looks like
and let's talk about what is going on
here so we generated an array here of
data from 1000 random arrays it looks
like they're mostly between minus four
and four and then it adds up each one it
says I'm zero you have 35
000 that are zero so that's what's most
common on here and we have 20 000 that
are somewhere in this range right here
between the minus two and well it looks
like one and minus two and somewhere
between zero and one there's thirty
thousand numbers so all this is saying
is this is how common these variables
are and this gives you this is a point
in so many directions when you're
looking at data science to go ahead and
run your histogram so you should always
have your histogram and you can always
put limits and all the other different
things on your rate just like you did on
the other graphs on there and then we're
going to do a cumulative detailed
histogram and all it is is a histogram
let me just do that
and we set cumulative equal to true
and bends equal 50. and I really want to
highlight the the cumulative equals true
is important but we can now choose how
many bins we have in the first one it
kind of selected them for us in this
case let me go ahead and run this and
you'll see it has the printed data out
for us and here's our whoops I must have
missed oh there we go doesn't help that
I put it over the old one there we go
okay so now you have your default
histogram and now we have a cumulative
histogram and we should have 50 steps in
there and let's just find out if that's
true not So Much by counting them I'm
not going to count them if you want to
you can count them let's just change it
to 10 and see what happens and we see
here we have now 10 counts of that
could set that for five
and run that
and then we have our five on there and
we go ahead and take the cumulative
equals true out just so you can see what
that looks like and let me run that on
here too
that looks just like it did before I
think there's what one two three four
five six seven eight they have eight
different bins on here is what the
default came out of
put that back in there run and so now it
should look almost identical and it does
and then we can put the cumulative back
in see what that looks like with the
cumulative
and run that
and we can see how that shifts
everything over and has a slightly
different look wait it shifts it all to
the right no it doesn't actually shift
it to the right it's cumulative so it's
a total of the different currencies and
so what that means is like if you
consider this like for the year of
rainfall we have like day one you had a
little bit of rain day two we have more
rain and so if you look at the number
this is a hundred thousand thirty five
thousand so it's a cumulative detail the
histogram the currents as it grows and
rainfall is a good one because that
would be a cumulative histogram of how
much rain occurred throughout the year
and we're going to look at two more
graphs we've already looked at a bunch
of them we looked at our radar graph
we've looked at scatter step bar fill in
basic plots we've looked at different
ways of showing the data and we can
increase the size of the line the look
the color the alpha setting
so let's look at contour maps just put
that in there there we go draw a contour
map and before we draw a contour map we
need to go ahead and create data for it
and if you have Contours your data is
all going to have three different values
so let's go ahead and create the data
here we have our you'd import your
matplot library your numpy so we have
our numbers array
and we'll import
matplot.cm and that's your color Maps so
you have all these different color maps
you can look at there's like hundreds of
color Maps so if you don't want to do
your own color you need to do your own
color map they're pretty diverse and of
course our PLT we're going to our PI
plot and to generate our different data
we're going to create a Delta 0.025 and
we'll start with X and we're going to
create an array between -3 and 3 and
Delta increments of 0.025
and we'll have our y we'll do something
similar and then we'll create our X Y
into a mesh grid again these are all
numpy commands so if you're not familiar
with these you'll want to go back and
review our numpy tutorial and we'll do
an exponential on here minus x squared
minus y squared for our Z1 we'll do a Z2
so we have two different areas and Z
equals z of one minus Z2 times 2. so
we've created a number of values here
and let me go ahead and run this and
let's plug that in so you can see where
those values are going so once we've set
these we're going to create our figure
and our X from our PLT subplots we're
going to create the variable Cs and this
is going to be our Contour so right here
CS is our Contour service and we're
feeding it X Y and Z if you remember X Y
we created as our X and Y components
using our mesh grid and you know what
let's do this just because it's kind of
good to see this let's go ahead and
print X and let's print Y and I always
like to do this when I'm working with
something this either is really
complicated in this case is what we're
looking at or you don't understand yet
so we've created a mesh grid we have x y
and when we're done with this we end up
with here's our X
and this set of values in our y so those
are X and Y coordinates and then we've
also created Z based on our X and Y so
we have x capital x capital Y and
capital Z is our three components X and
Y being the coordinates well Z is going
to be our actual height since we're
doing a contour map so we created our
contour map from our X Y and Z
coordinates we want to go ahead and put
in a c label maybe we want to go ahead
and do an title on here
we'll put that in our set title and this
is and let's go ahead and run this what
that looks like and you'll see we
generated a nice little contour map
there's different settings you can play
with on this but you can picture this
being you're on a mountain climb and
here we have a line that's represents
zero maybe that's sea level and then
moving on up you have your Contours of
0.5 and minus one and different setups
little Hills I guess if it's minus
that's like a pit so I guess you're
going down into a pit at minus five and
minus one but on the other side you can
see you're going up in levels so here's
a Mountaintop